90 day fiance star ben rathbun arrested
people are going to have very strong
opinions but i'm kind of made for that
e.t can confirm the 52-year-old reality
star was arrested on tuesday in michigan
according to tmz the arrest came as a
result of ben failing to appear at a
scheduled probation violation hearing
last month because he didn't show up the
judge issued a bench warrant ben's bond
has been set for ten thousand dollars
and his next hearing is scheduled for
march 21st
et has reached out to tlc for comment
of course this all stems from ben's
original arrest back in 2020 when he was
busted for owai operating while ability
impaired and he was sentenced to 18
months probation there's good and bad in
everything but i choose just to like
really focus on the good ben currently
stars in 90 day fiance before the 90
days which follows his relationship with
22 year old maogany from peru
oh my gosh
oh
you are real
the couple connected online and
eventually met in person when the former
pastor traveled to peru to meet mahogany
who initially stood him up at the
airport
she hasn't responded to me
i'm an activist
take two was more successful the pair
met at a restaurant and mahogany
apologized
oh my gosh i'm so sorry no you waste me
all too much time maybe that's fine oh
my gosh oh
oh my gosh wow
and now that their relationship is
public some fans are criticizing the
couple's 30-year age gap it's a topic
ben addressed in an interview with e.t
earlier this month so all the viewers
out there that are so concerned for her
and think that i'm you know a predator
and coming after a young girl this has
become so much more than age and so much
more
than than
you know
our differences
uh the things that we've been really
focusing on are our commonalities
and and so those so far outweigh our
differences and she is so mature and
wise and intelligent
that i haven't really felt that
difference but when the two initially
met things didn't exactly start off on
the right foot
22
[Music]
you don't know my age
i thought you're 24.
ben who has a daughter the same age as
his girlfriend told et how he learned to
get past it she didn't like keep
reiterating the lie it was a one-time
lie so not a problem to me at all i
don't you know have a 24 year old
but i do have a 22 year old so it just
um i thought if she's older than my kids
it just psychologically you know is not
that big of a deal and and even that
isn't that big of a deal to me
um
as far as the age of my kids because i
don't look at it that way she's a
completely separate adult
and it doesn't matter to me if um
you know my kids of that age it's just
something that kind of caught me off
guard and i had to think about it for a
minute although this wasn't the first
time mahogany wasn't entirely truthful
with ben in person mahogany does look a
little different than she does in the
pictures
and i could tell that her pictures that
she sent me were doctored a little bit
there's uh in my opinion two different
kinds of people that do social media
one is someone that wants to show what's
going on their life every single day
when i see
my oghani's page it's not like that at
all she like posts maybe once every two
or three months
and it's just for fun it's more for art
she never thought the entire world would
be looking at that and judging her for
it you know she was just having fun um
so i don't have any problem with it it's
fine it doesn't it doesn't really matter
so she's not trying to in my opinion
deceive anyone she's having a fun time
[Music]